I'm out joined here on the Rich Eisen
show by two friends and I'm pleased to
be able to say that and also even more
thrilled to be able to say that their
fantastic television show billions
returns for season five on Showtime at
9:00 Eastern and Pacific for the
creators of this show writers creators
producers they're the - and school or
Brian compliment and David Levine how
are you guys doing yeah rich good to see
you man good to see you back here richer
part of the family of the show man it is
a special thing for us when somebody
know like first of all you've been in
this enthusiastic booster of the show
since the very beginning that's the more
than that you came to play you were you
were jammed - it was not easy for you
and you turned your life inside out and
came to New York and then you know ya
they sit next to Bob mentary for five
hours put him next to a maniac was
hilarious and we loved we all loved
mannery he's the funniest man in the
world but like you just your
professionalism and heart that you
brought to that thing while men are is
next to you doing god knows what in
between setups well I got my it was my
pleasure to bring professionalism to
easily the worst fight in the history of
pugilism you know the gold that was the
gold dollar bill versus Murphy and the
crazy thing is Kelly a coin who plays
dollar bill in the show
I love yes he broke his rib during the
the episode that was shot for the
previous season right you broke those
Rivermen see well I think we have to
methey who you know was playing a
character that can't throw a punch
managed to throw the first punch in the
right way and break the guy's rib right
out of the gate and then he had been
Kelly had to suffer through nine-hour as
a shooting with a broken rib if you
think about it like we think of the fee
and the way we talk about him of his
goofy think but I mean Dan Soder is a
big man he's six - he played high school
football he's a good athlete and you
know I guess he got in there and those
instincts just kind of took over though
I guess the great athlete could pull the
punch yeah you know what and it was just
a glorious day on the stand
to watch the season play out and then
just another brilliant season of your
show billions again on Showtime that
returns Sunday night at 9:00 Eastern and
I it's it's just I can't wait for it so
Brian want you to go first what what
what can people expect this season what
is the plot line for this season well
I'll say this you know we left off last
season with things at a pretty
heightened place where Chuck and and and
Taylor and acts kind of realized their
turn earned again one another and this
season does pick up dealing with sort of
where these loyalties sit there are new
characters who show up this year who are
very important there's a character named
Mike Prince played by Corey Stoll who
you might remember from from any number
of the you know the first season of
house of cards and he plays Hemingway in
that woody movie and he's had his own
show the state he's just an incredible
actor and he's a rival billionaire to
axe and so now axe has at least a two
front and may be a three front war going
as Chuck is really mounting his attack
and then you have Taylor trying to
figure out how they can come out on top
so there is a lot of rock and a lot of
role in this season David what do you
got to add well how am I gonna come
after rockin and a-rollin well this is
what I try to like you know it is I just
try to do this so that you can do this
yeah I mean I think you did this and
this for yourself I you know a rockin
and a-rollin I'm gonna leave it at that
I can't take it up from there you're
saying I said it and I self spiked elf
spike so when when when this season
begins it picks up obviously where the
last one ended in terms of cameos the
sports stars that have been on this
program have been remarkable Durant I
think made one last year do you have any
more because the the number of sports
fans that are fans of your show it's a
it's kind of a perfect Venn diagram
overlapping well clearly after you were
on we're going to take a big
in the Cameo Department it's very much
off to recover from that but you know we
don't want to spoil any of the cameos
but we've been super lucky to have
incredibly fascinating and talented
people come on board as fans of the show
and if we can reach out to them through
social media or if Brian happens to know
them as a close personal friend then you
know we'll Dragoon them into service on
the show I will say Dave one of them is
gonna get spoiled ahead of time so I'm
we can spoil it because he's in the
trailer okay he's in that look-ahead
trailer now hmm so and it and which will
air Sunday but his episode is first
episode is is the following week so we
did get and it's been incredible
actually incredible to us guys our age
the human highlight film Dominique
Wilkins makes a great appearance this
season so and Dominique Wilkins might be
okay so Dominique Wilkins will appear on
billions maybe before the last dance is
what you're saying but he's been they've
shown him briefly in the last day of
dunking maybe but yes he is I've watched
all four uh he's he's great I'll say
this neat comes to play as he always did
so uh he's above the rim on billions and
he brings it to handed riptide dunk
performance is Derrick dave was there I
think there's a rumor I heard that there
was a horse game that happened yeah I
think maybe between setups a challenge
was uh was lobbed at him by one of the
show runners and I think we were tight
for time so it wasn't horse I believe it
was pig but how did that work out what
how did that play out you know now that
you bring it up I remember I played him
in pig and I destroyed him the shot was
falling that day wasn't it it was a
crazy thing fifty people are watching
and I went to the one-handed
three-pointers and and this is the truth
he was at first not taking it too
seriously and then I made a couple of
them in a row and then somehow I beat
him and I was trying to get out of there
because you know athletes rich you know
how they are here and I really beat him
in pig and then I was like well this is
great and he goes no no no you can't
handle like that and I said well just
did
we gotta get the P the I and the G
that's we're done now right and he
stands in front of the exit he's like no
one more one more and this is so great
and I stupidly went all right I mean
we're going to say no to him and he was
so pissed that I beat him in front of
everybody big by the way the greatest
guy in the world literally among the
sweetest smartest guys it's incredible
the success that he is in life and
everything and you could see why cuz
then he went one more I missed I shot
first
I noticed he went to the half-court line
and he just three in a row
boom boom boom it just took me out at
half court Brian David Levine the
co-creators producers writers of
billions on Showtime that returns again
Sunday night at 9:00 Eastern Time right
here on the Rich Eisen show the show
kind of got a little bit of a pop when
Mets purchase was up for conversation
recently and that the potential buyer of
the Mets was your guys inspiration for
the Bobby Axelrod character on the show
is that is there any truth to that rumor
at all Brian David that you are basing
that act was based on talk about a rod
now now that not Alex Rodriguez
definitely not Alex Rodriguez Steve
Cohen I believe the owner or the boy he
was a potential under the Mets is that
was that is there any truth you know
that story was was sort of floating
around out there because he was in the
press a lot when the show was just
breaking but the character is not based
none of the characters are based on any
one individual you know they're
fictional constructs we've met and
researched many people both walks of
life you know the prosecutorial side and
the investment side but it wouldn't be
accurate to say that it's based on
anybody and not Steve calm the only
character we've ever based on one person
in the whole history of our career was
Joey knish and rounders was based on a
real guy named Joel bagels and that's it
that extent of it in the history of you
guys working together that's the only
guy the fish knishes the guy that's it
where where is a knish these days do we
know and I sadly we do
way onto his reward founder not promised
to be a long one sometimes but he was a
great guy
and super generous with his uh he was
like our guide into the underground
poker world in New York and he really
did have the truck you know how Matt
Damon's character borrows the guys
pastry truck when he get he busts out
and he's driving it the real guy it was
called Joel bagels cuz he had a pastry
truck that he would loan out when guys
were in trouble it was all true but
other than that we make it up we combine
people's you know you take a
characteristic from this guy a notion
from that and and you build an entirely
new character you got Edward Norton on
the show several months ago when he was
on to promote motherless Brooklyn and he
said he must definitely be and everybody
everybody would be interested in a
rounders update is there anything in the
cards on that the cards in the car like
that wow you like that that is
professional broadcasting that's what
the difference is
that's the separate that's how it gets
separated out Dave one speed what do you
think if you're avoiding the question or
because I love you guys I'd love to see
it what do you think the questions a
heartbreaker you know that this is a an
idea that we've gathered up the
participants and gotten ready to go
numerous times over the years we've had
meetings with money people we've been
ready and then you know this in this
crazy sort of web of Hollywood rights
happened where companies were sold and
then other companies bought the
underlying rights and then weren't ready
to make movies and honestly you got so
confusing if we just keep run into a
brick wall with it we have all the
actors we have John Dahl the director
ready to go but we can't just get a
clear in fact mr. mr. Malkovich wrote
wrote us yesterday and not about that
but he wrote us yesterday just checking
in on some stuff saying hi we talked to
Matt frequently we talked to Edward all
the time as you know Malkovich was in
billions also and and so when someone
comes to us we're
they say we have the rights to the movie
we were ready to pay people to do it we
would all try to do it but it's been
very difficult to sort out and you know
rich everybody every day somebody asks
us online and I have fun with it
where they answering their question but
nobody would like to do that more than
us I mean we're visiting the characters
who started our career and we see the
way people bought bonded with these
characters you know you walk around with
Edward a mad I mean that still would
people bring up to them and Malkovich
says the same thing and and it would be
an honor to figure out how to do it if
we ever could get it get it going yeah
it does seem that you know Malkovich was
channeling his inner Teddy KGB Porter
the show it seemed like he was kind of
reprising that role in a slight bid we
knew that the audience like we did have
him say the word satisfied once like we
knew the audience would make that
connection even though the characters
were very different it's like there were
like long runs at certain poker sites
where people were figuring out how they
put Teddy KGB went back to Russia became
an oligarch and then came back here
under debited none of that oh it's great
I mean it'd be one of the all-time runs
to go from a backyard guy and in 20
years roll up 20 billion dollars in
Russia and then compacted by the
Islanders a great run well you know in a
few minutes I have left with you here
the actors actresses on your show are
just so amazing there's their you know
obviously Damian Lewis and and Giamatti
stand up maggie siff is a favorite of
mine they're all terrific only one of
them however is related to baseball
royalty and I'm wondering and I know you
guys are big sports fans again does the
subject of of Paul G Mounties dad ever
come up on the set or is it just
something that that's asked answered I
can answer it like this um you know Paul
lost his dad when his dad was young
right so I think any conversations we
have about Bart Giamatti are best left
sort of like personal conversations it's
not really a part of it's not really a
part of the show once he had to
reference Pete Rose and and he did it
without on the show Chuck Rhodes had to
mention Pete Rose
and he did and we just all kind of
played through it yeah I mean and and I
I kind of feel a little bit like a heel
even ants asking the question because it
is such a personal thing but you know
he's such an amazing actor and he is to
me one of the all-time greats yeah and
his father was a legend as his father
he's one of the greatest guy everybody
who ever comes up to me to talk about
Bart Giamatti for this reason they
always have a an amazing personal story
about a way that Bart Giamatti touched
their lives changed their lives he was
clearly a great man I think I said we
both agree we would have been great to
get to know that guy because his son is
one of the greatest guys in the whole
world
absolutely occasionally somebody on set
who's been to Yale or knew his dad will
come up and share an anecdote with him
and it means a lot to him how he touches
people and and Paul loves hearing about
it yeah I'm sure just just you know
anybody whose dad would passed away
would love to hear when they came across
you know or a story like that and I
don't know I'm just curious as to as to
if he you know talks about it or if it's
anything like that because it is such an
important part of sports history and
what a role his father did play no of
course of course yeah I wish I would
have I to Li the way people talk about
that guy even you know the golf writer
Michael Bamberger he you know the great
golfer I just wrote that great book
about Tiger Woods so I Bamberger was on
my my podcast recently we know each
other we're friendly and he knew Bart
Giamatti from Bart Giamatti changed his
life basically Bart Giamatti and Paul
made that guy want to be a writer get
stories for days about how incredible
Bart Giamatti is so you do hear that
everywhere but as I say Paul keeps that
stuff mostly himself so the future of
billions for those who may not know this
is this the penultimate season there's
gonna be one more do you you want to
make more what what what can you tell us
about billions partner I hope never ends
well we're yeah we're ready to keep
rolling you know we'll keep doing it as
long as it's fresh and exciting to us
and as long as the network wants to keep
going and it seems like that's firing on
both sides you know they don't order it
many years in advance we only go one at
a time but we are we are not planning on
wrapping it up any time soon
from our end of it
I can imagine as long as there's greed
and as long as there's you know
capitalism and as long as that's a
driving force for a lot of people in
this world I kind of think you guys have
a ton of stuff to work with right it
greed is going anywhere soon
I mean capitalism looked a little rocky
for a minute there but it's probably
okay now that Bernie didn't get the
nomination
well I and I and I I dunno obviously and
then you know we could we could begin to
wrap up our conversation maybe around
this is what is going on in this world
you know I'm talking to you right now
from the corner of my desk that I did
all of my NFL Draft coverage and how
immensely popular that it was and and to
have you guys now with your series come
in right now it is just perfectly timed
for people who want to lose themselves
and that but that said at some point you
know everyone will get back to work and
so will the industry that you guys are
so prevalent in and then I imagine there
will be stories and everything will be
run through the prism of what we're
going through right now I'm fascinated
to know what Bobby Axelrod and Chuck
Rhodes life would be in a coronavirus or
post koban 19 world soar I mean so are
we you know that'll be we will start
writing season six over the summer and
we put all the stuff that's going on in
the world you know into the Opera and
and we'll figure it out certainly look I
I just look at that I mean I'm Dave and
I talk about this all the time I'm it's
funny someone just texted Dave and me
earlier today say how you doing and and
levena I thought your answer was perfect
and it's like beside the point out we're
doing I mean there's so many people hurt
and man it's like and that was an awful
I mean Dave was just saying that to a
buddy it's like you know we're all the
three of us are all in a pretty good
spot here we have jobs that we like
doing and we have some food on the table
in a house and and so when we get back
into it
figuring out how these characters are
processing it and what's going on will
be certainly fascinating thing to do
right now
I think the two of us are thinking a lot
about just people and you know seeing
online the way people talk about being
excited about the show coming back if
that gives them an hour or two of
distraction and like some joy then that
feels great to us and and lucky to be
able to be a part of that for people
it's um you know it's a it's such an
intense and strange time for so many
people and the only way I can look at
what our show might bring is how much I
miss sports you know I miss I miss what
sports give me the ability to
concentrate on something outside of my
life something that takes me away my
miss marveling at what athletes can do
under pressure and oh you know I can't
wait for that to come back I know David
you feel the same way and I can't you
know I'm thrilled that our show can can
be that for some people David appreciate
it I'm appreciated really appreciate
your time here thanks so much I can't
wait for the beginning of your your show
coming up Sunday 9:00 Eastern Time every
Sunday night on showtime bilions is just
a brilliant program i can't recommend it
highly enough people should binge watch
it if they haven't caught up and if
they've caught up you know my wife and I
will spend a little part of of this
weekend catching up just to make sure
that we're we're as fresh as a daisy
when that's awesome it's nice thanks so
much rich thanks for being such a friend
of the show and Fred to us we really
appreciate and you've got it you got it
this Brian compliment that's David
Levine of billions on show time right
here in the Rich Eisen show